and I'm standing on the subway and I
have to stand up to show you I'm
standing on the subway like this this is
me on the subway and there's a person
here you know this is my corresponding
you get yours the stander and there's
your sitter look or at dhikr they're
just right there I mean that's what they
have no choice they're sitting like this
and you're standing over I mean women
are decent and they stand like sideways
we just go like hey but anyway he's
instead usually they tune out your dick
like this but he's looking right at it
right here so he's looking and he's kind
of looking at it like what's up with
that yeah and then he looks up at me and
he goes and that's not that makes me
uncomfortable and then he goes points
right at my dick and then I realized I
looked down at my fly is open not only
not only is it open it's aggressively
it's like
it's not like a pants like a slit like a
pants vagina it's like a like a grizzly
bears [ __ ] that would be okay I was
on a plane I was going flying out to Los
Angeles recently for a lot of important
stuff and I was in the and sitting on a
the aisle seat with two you know with
three seats neck it was like a very
crowded stressful flight and we're about
to take off and this woman gets on with
her baby like this and her husband and
two other just sad looking kids and
she's just walking through the plane
hating people with her baby so upset and
I saw her coming I realized that she's
sitting here no and I'm like uh so she
comes up and she says okay here's how
this is gonna work this is all true she
goes you're sitting in the middle I'm
sitting in the aisle because I have a
baby oh and I thought okay
and I told her here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna get off the plane
[Applause]
well I was in Arizona and there I was a
I forget what I was going to say they
driven do radios to do radio by this
woman who worked at this club that I was
working at and she gets this parking lot
and it's automated and it gives
instructions in English in Spanish and
she goes that's South ffensive if you're
gonna be in this country then just learn
English and I said well what's wrong
with giving people to speak Spanish an
option and she says because it's just
you don't understand his Mexicans it's
just they're really like if you live
down here then like Mexicans like just
generally in Mexico and I said you know
I'm Mexican Mexican I lived there till I
was seven I only spoke English when I
came here I came to America as a little
Mexican boy was coming to me America muy
bonito
[Music]
but I don't know she didn't know that I
said you're Mexican and she said she
said oh well I don't it's not that I
don't like Mexicans it's just that
there's so many of them it's okay to be
racist towards a group as long as it's
just that there's a lot under a certain
number they're fine like ten thousand
they start to get smelly in bed are you
and that's my favorite thing to do in
the whole wide world I'll probably take
a couple more before I go to bed I'll
just love it's my favorite thing you
like it better than sleep you bet it
this sleeve is like the ultimate now you
really stupid you just said but that's
not what I'm saying I'm saying if you
take a nap are you laying down yes and
and are you in a bed or I can depend I
mean that's okay can you get just forget
past this part miss thing you could ask
me is like that's better than sleeping
it is it's sleeping that's what an app
is you were were you a bad kid it wasn't
vacuum I got in trouble because I just
was alone and I just you know like I got
into stealing tampons
no I didn't make a dime I didn't make a
dime I hesitated I was eight years old
and I just went into a CVS one day
because I just roamed store aisles and
and I was at looking at the tampons and
I was sort of staring at them with this
I knew there was something dirty about
it
Darren and I picked one up I got the
gall to pick one up and I'm looking at
this box tampons and someone came around
a corner as I put in my jacket and now I
have stolen them yeah because if I take
them out that someone saw that I had
them in my check I my head I'm like
that's it they're in there I can't so I
just I left and I had sweat on my face
and I just went home and I threw him
under my bed and I'm eating dinner like
everybody knows that you have tampons
over my bed and so it was a terrible
stressful experience which I then
repeated every day I'd go back and I
just do the whole cycle I just kept
doing it like no I never got caught I
mean they probably saw me but the guys
like I'm not confronting the kid I'll
pay for him out of my check before I
live that moment I'm not asking that
little pervert what he's doing with it
there's something wrong with that boy
well they kept going under my bed and I
just tried not to think about him and
then one day I looked and they were just
gone they just were gone and my mom
never said anything she just she must be
cleaning over she was like what maybe
she used them for like ten years
sowhat's ago my dog and your dog eaten
the whole big bar of dark polish
chocolate the Polish part doesn't matter
but I like saying Polish chocolate and
my dog had chocolate on her face and and
I went oh my god and she looked at me
like I was home for an hour alone what
are you gonna you know come on and I was
like you're gonna die and she's looking
at me like I don't understand English
but I get that you're upset
hydroxide into this dog but I don't have
any so I've got to go to the pharmacy
and she needs to come with me cuz
there's no time I'm in New York City and
I take my daughter put the leash on her
she's like excited we're going for a
walk and I'm running and she's like this
is great for you you never exercises
she's just enjoying
and then we get to the pharmacy and
she's waiting for me when I come out and
I've got a bottle of hydrogen peroxide
that I have to make her drink yeah like
take yourself through that how do you
make a dog like you just here drink this
you know so I kind of pour a little in
her snout she goes like that and so I
kind of grabbed her and I pour once she
she goes I think I was pretty clear that
I didn't like that like she looks at me
like and so I get my whole body around
her this dog was 70 pounds she's like an
alligator
if she didn't want a dress on she's just
thrashing on my trinket and at one point
I have her on the end of the leash and
she's looking at me
all wet in the face and she gives me
this look like I don't know what
happened to you but our thing is over
and she starts going on she became
completely vicious just trying to bite
me and I'm trying to save her life
yeah so I'm literally I'm punching her
in the face I think a lot of people
don't do their job is they don't like
their job I don't get that you know like
if you go to app like a coffee place
something and the kid looks you like I'm
like I didn't come to your house to ask
you for coffee I think it's a coffee
place if you work here
your clothes matches the building I had
a right to expect
you're closer to the coffee machine I
don't know why and I need coffee I don't
know why someone wouldn't want their job
to go really well all right and I think
usually it's cuz they're 20 because 20
year old douchebags that don't want to
do I am prejudiced against 20 year olds
really yeah because 19 you're still your
parents fault right 20 you're
technically an adult but you still
haven't done anything like 20 year olds
if their jobs are always like this job
sucks yes that's why we gave it to you
your 20 year olds old you haven't done
anything than ever
you've just been sucking up resources
you've just been taking food and love
and education and iPods and just taking
it and judging is you I look good sucks
you're like a big orange on a tree
that's rotting and the trees like it so
I decided I don't want to be on the
internet anymore I don't like the way it
feels anymore especially on my in my
hand the devices I don't like this thing
that I stare into this thing and it just
it makes me feel upset and I look at
things that I know are gonna upset me
you know I guess I just liked the hit
from going oh yeah you know like I'll go
on my computer and I'll like Google an
image I don't want to see so then I see
a whole wall of it yeah you know a big
dicks with nails in them
sir you're gonna have to leave the
library yeah tell people I'm fascinated
about how you got the the show on FX
I have the show they said we want you to
do a TV show what did you say well I
didn't need a TV show I was in a unique
position I was on the road doing
stand-up and I liked it so they said you
want to do a TV show I was like okay but
only if I get to do it the way I want
and they go yeah we'll give you a lot of
creative freedom and I said we want you
to see know what the shows about until
it's totally completed and they said
well that's unreasonable
we need to oversee programs that are on
our show and I said of course so as I do
it it's a great position yeah so they
said okay we'll let you do the show
without supervision but then they said
we need to know who's on the show and I
said I'm not telling you and they said
we can't have a show populated by people
we don't even know who they are and I
said of course you can't exactly now go
you got a Twitter page and I you know
I've known you for a long time I didn't
know that you were into social media are
you are you that interested in it well I
kind of hate it I think it's awful and
uh you have Twitter so that I can just
tell people when I'm you know what I
want them to buy with and give me money
I don't care people get mad at me
because I don't follow anybody I zero
people that I follow people are like
your arrogant prick like I get really
angry really how dare you not follow but
why do they care it doesn't it's like a
piece of cake going come on man one's
right here why aren't you eating me
I'm sorry himtell on television but uh I
don't I think it's better I think you
shouldn't just do everything that's
available to do isn't a good idea
there's a culture right now that as soon
as they hey you get to do that I'm gonna
do it sort of like maybe that's not just
the constant nobody takes in life unless
it comes through this yes like whenever
I see a televised event that's a huge
like the Olympics Opening Ceremony or a
Time Square at midnight on New Year's
Eve everybody they see sees of people
all looking at it through their phone
like there's explosions and acrobats but
they're looking at it through a little
3-inch screen like I think if Jesus
comes back and starts telling everyone
everything
it'll just everybody's just gonna be
twittering and they won't really I am
Christ and I have retained oh my god
Jesus is right in front of me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but this is I'm now going to impart to
you I have Twitpic of Jesus oh my god
sending Jesus is trending right now you
just look at me first I don't believe in
saving money I think it's arrogant it's
arrogant to say huh because you could
die yeah and it's like holding an
umbrella breathing I'm not letting it
out I worked hard for this you know I
don't and it's not a good attitude
because I have children yeah and I
should be saving for them and I'm way
not not saying it's really bad
so not preparing for their future or
even near presence wow they have no idea
how close to oblivion they are right now
if I if I die tonight they'll be
homeless tomorrow morning while it lasts
they'll get both pieces of news at the
same time daddy's dead and get your get
out now so why work so much of money as
well usually think why should they get
the money yeah I did the shows why do
they get the money right yeah I don't
believe in it I don't believe in raising
your kids rich right is the worst thing
you can do for that we're really more
for the people that they're gonna impact
later in life yeah because there's no
way somebody who's raised rich is not
gonna be a piece of human being
[Applause]
[Music]